greetings and peace welcome to the dean
shaw met your host we got a really
exciting show for
you obama just recently gave a nice
little talk at a masjid
i'm going to be talking about this and
we're going to be talking about the
frenzy of fear that has been perpetuated
here
in america and a lot more on this week's
show don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
this is
connect your heart to god given charity
experience tell me uh how you've been
since then uh i'm the lab
transition from the department of
corrections as a muslim chaplain to
working with guidance tv
and now working with the islamic online
university
has been quite busy with that that trip
was a very memorable one
indeed it was quite quite quite a
memorable one i think that was your
first horizon
second that was my second that was your
second one in 2006.
and that was 2008. i was honored to be
able to share that with you me too it
was an amazing experience
and we went there seeking to connect
with the owner of peace
indeed that first house of worship was
built by abraham
right and you have people from all walks
of life coming to commemorate the
worship one god
and malcolm x what did he say he said
you know you know the quote by malcolm
about
ending racism yes he when he got there
he found out that his brothers
were from all nations that he he could
no longer call the caucasians the white
devils as he had been taught
that he had caucasian brothers and
african brothers and
you see european brothers asian brothers
so this is our deen this is islam you
know it's a universal way
and and that would um islam if
implemented it would end racism
absolutely
all these benefits all of the great
things that are
there for humanity and islam but now
there's a free fear frenzy
so you guys someone's out there is like
what are you guys talking about you're
just sugar coating
mickey mouse coastedness islam mickey
mouse in this islam no no you guys are
violent and extremist you want to just
you know do jihad on everybody
and this is the this is the challenge
that we as muslims in america and
throughout the world are faced with
today
and that is to convey the correct image
of islam and the correct practice of
islam
as you know we're in a very highly
politicized
season and environment where islam and
muslims
have become one of the main topics and
unfortunately most of the society
do not know the real islam they don't
know many of them don't know any muslims
or have not had any interaction so
they naturally feed into the fear that
is brought to them from political
leaders from the election cycle
uh from their their you know churches or
the media you know that has given a bad
impression in in the portrayal of what
islam is and who the muslims are
what about the speech president obama
this was an amazing an amazing event
that
has certainly i i wish that more
muslims knew about it and certainly more
citizens of the united states
he was invited to speak at the islamic
society of baltimore just yesterday and
cnn broadcast the entire speech he spoke
for about 45 minutes
and he spoke about the inclusiveness of
the american
values that we as muslims have
and of course he didn't say himself as a
muslim but that we as muslim have
have a place here in america that we've
made tremendous contributions to the
society and so that we should not be
uh treated with bigotry or any kind of
hostility in such a way to be excluded
we hear some of the political leaders
are calling for muslims to be
denied entry into the country from other
other countries all of us out of fear
you see so his effort to reach out to
the muslims was
really a very very courageous move on
his part and
it was very interesting he made a point
that another president was accused of
being a muslim too
which one was that thomas jefferson so
keith tell me about when you took your
oath of office because it was
on a copy of the quran and not just any
copy well in fact it was on this
quran that we have right here before us
and uh you know in fact uh this quran
which is a two volume set
has the initials uh tj inscribed right
here
thomas jefferson and so you know we we
said this was your reaction when you
found out that one of the founding
fathers had his own copy of the quran
right
i was gobsmacked oh because they had the
quran
exactly he had him said he said this was
true that thomas jefferson was accused
of being a muslim
so he felt he was in good company yeah
but you know that brings us to the point
about the fact that we are as muslims
face with the challenge of
of portraying and practicing our
religion with the correct understanding
of islam
and so it makes it very important for us
as muslims to
to fulfill one of the commandments from
our prophet muhammad god's peace and
blessing
upon him and that is to to to seek the
knowledge that it is incumbent it's an
obligation upon every muslim
to learn this deen to learn the
fundamentals of islam
because when we do that and when we take
our knowledge from the authentic sources
and from credible
credible teachers then this safeguards
us
against a misinterpretation or incorrect
practices
it safeguards us from going off into
extremes
you see and and this is a big challenge
that we're faced with today
uh where sometimes we we will learn
something but
without the correct guidance in in
guidance in that process of learning
we will go on our own emotion and as a
result we can sometimes
be led into an extreme practice or an
extreme
understanding and so this leads to
problems
not only uh uh in in the
middle east where we see conflicts after
conflicts
uh muslims fighting against muslims and
and and so on and so forth
but we see it even in our own
communities where you know we
we have a great need to to rise above
this and to have unity
you also come from a christian
background is that right that's correct
you accepted islam how long ago i i
accepted islam in 1976 i was raised as a
catholic i was an altar boy actually in
the church
catholic church in washington dc and and
alhamdulillah
after i learned about islam you know it
was no looking back
any regrets none whatsoever in fact for
me it was like all the pieces of the
puzzle came together
you see and alhamdulillah what one of
the things that has
really uh stirred my love for this
deen for this way of life is the
emphasis that it places on
on the knowledge in in other faiths
in the faith that i was raised in uh we
weren't obligated to learn
the religion we left it up to the
priests the deacons or the bishops the
cardinals the popes
the ministers and other faiths are
similar to that
but in islam each and every muslim is
obligated
to study his religion to study his deen
and
so that he can practice it in the best
manner in the way that the prophet
muhammad
peace be upon him has taught us to do so
we're here on the dean show with the
director
us director of islamic online university
university
you're currently representing the
university here
in the states yes along with my my very
able assistant sister yes mean rolando
you'll
be meeting shortly we are responsible
for promoting the university here
and encouraging raising the enrollment
uh for the university
one of the responsibilities that i've
been tasked with is also to provide the
the course of study to the inmate
population across the country
all right we're going to talk some more
of that we got a lot more to talk about
donald trump making some statements i
want to get your feedback on that and
other politicians
now people want to get elected seems
like uh muslims are the guinea pigs here
escape goes we're gonna be right back
with more don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
and don't forget as i asked you to do
already
if you haven't subscribe right now
back here on the dean show with the us
director
of the islamic online university
and tell me how would you respond
and this is a misconception that many
people have and then you have
people out there who have the microphone
the platform donald trump for instance
and others
who they'll say look you know i was just
in malaysia
i was here and these muslims are just
blowing things up i just left
indonesia bomb bomb bomb right we got a
problem
i would i would encourage the people
themselves to do as malcolm said
think for yourself don't let others
think for you
and get to know the muslims get to know
what islam is all about
we have more than 2 000 mosques all
across the country
we have perhaps as many as 1200 or more
muslim schools
and we are your neighbor we are the
neighbors of of
of the society and so we encourage them
to
get to know the muslims from the the
direct interaction and not leave it up
to
someone else making an uninformed
opinion just because they want your vote
and they're feeding on your fear
you see fear is is an industry in itself
as you well know
yeah uh they they make movies that
people spend billions of dollars just to
go and become frightened
and so the politicians know that and so
they'll use that fear
as a means to feed into their need to
get voted to get elected
and so unfortunately as you mentioned we
as muslims
we're now the islam is the boogie man
there's no more communism
you see so now the shift the focus has
been shifted to islam and muslims as
being the enemy
are unjustly so because once the people
really find out that islam
is a complete way of life about
submission and surrender to the will of
almighty god
the same way that all of the prophets
and messengers practice that jesus
submitted and surrendered his will to
god moses surrendered and submitted his
will to god
abraham our father peace be upon all of
them they will see that this is none
other than the divinely
revealed way that almighty god intended
for all human beings to live
now there was a documentary where they
follow
follow around some muslims and
if someone says look hold on hold on i
just saw the jihadi next door i don't
know if you saw this documentary
in uk how do you address a situation
like that where you do have elements
you know are they representing the true
face of islam and this is unfortunate
because
this is giving a bad reputation to uh
muslims in the mainstream of islam the
the dean
of islam teaches us to be balanced to be
um a moderate way so uh dean agusta
the the the way is that it's not extreme
in fact the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi
he he condemned extremism very clearly
he said that the extremists will be
destroyed
and so when we see you see
our young brothers and sisters who seem
to be following this
this extremist tendency or this radical
tendency they want to condemn
everyone who doesn't think like them or
believe like them or practice like them
even they'll condemn other muslims you
see this this
this is a a serious problem that we have
to look at
and study its roots study it it's the
causes
why people may slip into this arena
doctor uh sheikh jamal dean zara bulger
has a very very beautiful book on
religious extremism
that addresses this topic in detail and
and
and i think with the work that we're
doing with the university and trying
to bring the correct understanding of
islam and from authentic sources
this helps to alleviate and minimize the
tendency towards extremism
and even though this is a very small
fringe element
combating that is something that you
guys are doing
muslims i mean such as sheikh bala
phillips
dr phillips you representing the islamic
online university here
and that's through that continuing
legacy of education
yes because through education hopefully
this ignorance can be eradicated and
then we can
go ahead and um eradicate most of these
extremists by educating them in the
proper way
and and one of the things that goes
along with every act of worship of the
muslim
as you well know is is the sincerity the
intention
and and and so if a person tends to lean
towards extremism
you have to question the sincerity and
his humility because once you
learn you realize how little you do know
but some people will learn something and
and they begin to think that they are
the big shaykhs or so on and so forth
and begin to
question and condemn everyone and then
this you know also is a part of
that problem so how important is it i
mean
for every muslim to be climbing i call
it the spiritual ladder
right we don't want to be stuck in
kindergarten first grade to be
seeking knowledge to to understand the
importance of
taking the dean serious and and you
can't be serious in the dean if you're
not educating yourself
in the dean exactly you know and and
it's very important for us to
to not just do it on our own but to to
identify those scholars who are credible
and authentic
who are connected to the prophet
muhammad ali system
in the in the traditions the correct
traditions of of
understanding islam to study islam in a
programmatic way in a very disciplined
way so it's not to be scattered in
and out on your own you see where you
will begin to make
judgments and make and make uh or commit
certain actions that may very well be
uh out of context so it is very
important and and
indeed you know allah tells us in the
quran is the one who knows like the one
who does not know
you see and and so we we are obligated
to
be i like to say that we are an ummah of
scholarship we are a nation of
scholarship that encourages
the muslim to be educated because we are
going to be held responsible for what we
do
and that's why with i'm so delighted to
work with dr bilal and the staff of the
islamic online university
because we're bringing education to the
muslim
nation at a relatively nominal cost
tuition free you see there's no cost per
credit hour and we're not just focusing
on islamic studies or islamic education
or arabic language
but we've also expanded our offerings to
include
psychology business and finance
economics
education information and technology
computer
science of course in the arabic and
islamic studies
both the graduate and the undergraduate
course
offerings are available as well as the
free diploma program
so there's really no excuse for muslims
today to be uneducated
and you don't have to necessarily travel
to go a long way to
to be a student of knowledge it's very
difficult sometimes to travel these days
you see and go and stay so you can study
right in the convenience of your home
with the islamic online university if
you have access to the internet or
computer
and you don't have to enroll in the
graduate or undergraduate course so you
can take the diploma course
which you provided to the inmates across
the country
free of cost completely with no
registration costs
and uh and move at your own pace we're
going to take a break and then
i think we got a surprise we got
the head of the islamic online
university he's going to be with us on
the dean show don't go anywhere
right back please subscribe to the d
show follow us on our official facebook
and twitter pages in the links below
please
also help support the d show by making a
donation in the link below
and don't forget as i asked you to do
already
if you haven't subscribe right now
welcome back to the dean show and i what
the director of the islamic online
university for the united states
and you've also worked many years you're
still
helping people find purpose in the
prisons yes
how's that going alhamdulillah it's it's
it's been an amazing journey for me
actually i started working with the
prisons as a muslim chaplain
early on when i became muslim back in
1976
and i'm happy to have been a part of a
class-action suit in 78
to actually get islam islamic rights in
the prisons
where they could have jummah and other
activities
in the state of connecticut i served as
the full-time muslim chaplain
for about 10 years in south carolina and
also the contract demand for the federal
group prison seven
correctional facilities throughout the
southeast that i would visit
from florida up through georgia and
carolina and now
working with the islamic online
university dr willel has asked that we
provide
the diploma program to the muslim
inmates all across the country
and so that's been we have over 800
students now
and this is uh
this has been working very very well we
have over 800 students registered
inmates
of more than 300 now actually enrolled
in the classes
and they received the materials free of
charge there's six levels of study
foundation of islamic studies uh the
moral foundation of islamic culture
the effect of tahara the foundation the
understanding of the purification
also the arabic reading and writing it's
it's a very comprehensive course of
study for the
for the muslim inmates and we hope that
this will give them a
sound foundation so that when they do
return to society
they will not only be good sound
practicing muslims
but they will also be responsible
citizens who are dedicated to
giving back to the society because
they're receiving this effort
uh free free of cost and no charge how
long ago did you accept islam how long
has it been now
in 1976 over 30 some years over 30 years
yes and where you are right now you're
helping educate you were someone who got
educated
you found your purpose in life you saw
the proof
and evidence that islam provided you
come from a christian catholic
background
you obviously looked at all of the you
know evidence you didn't jump in this
blindly
obviously and now what has helped you
progress
is seeking knowledge you know dedicating
your time putting aside enough time to
to um work your heart through climbing
that spiritual ladder so what advice do
you have
for the people watching for the muslims
out there who now
they've tuned in and the heart is kind
of uh
depleted right it's empty like the phone
batteries you know depleted and then you
have some not yet muslims and they're
getting a different perspective when
they watch the dean's show you know
the prophet salallahu salmon gave us a
very beautiful hadith he said that
whoever sets out on the path to acquire
the knowledge of this deen
they're on the path to paradise until
they return so
my advice is is to to stay committed to
increasing one's knowledge of of islam
in all of its aspects
because this is what's going to bring
you closer to allah
is going to enable us to fulfill our
purpose more completely
and hopefully enable us to arrive at our
destination
which will be the paradise agenda uh in
the in the next life
because this is only a temporary life as
you and all of us who all know
yes and then the not yet muslims were
out there they tuned in for the first
time what advice do you have from them
i i advise them to to to give an open
keep an open mind to to study islam
and other religions and make a sound
choice based on the evidence it's based
on the proofs
because islam is not just blind belief
as some other faiths are
but it is based on on proof it's based
on truth
and so in order to allay
any fear that they may have they need to
get to know their neighbors get to know
us as muslims
many mosques are opening their doors for
open houses throughout the year
where they can come and find out that
we're not these strange you know
uh ideologues that that are out to
terrorize the society will take over
you see we want to share the goodness
that almighty god has given us
by following the paths of the prophets
uh in obedience to
our creator i heard we got a surprise
when we come back we got dr bilal
phillips
all right don't go anywhere we'll be
right back please subscribe to the d
show follow us on our official facebook
and twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
i'd like to give my greetings to
all of the viewers of the dean show
with brother eddie and of course it's a
great pleasure to
be back here with you again after a
number of years
we've been in different sides of the
world so we haven't had the opportunity
to sit and share uh
more understanding about the deen you
know dr bilal one of the main things
that we
talk about here in the dean show is the
message of peace the message of purpose
and we struggle hard to combat any form
of extremism
with providing the authentic knowledge
how do you personally contribute to this
struggle
i am the chancellor of the islamic
online university
whose focus is basically spreading
authentic islamic knowledge to make this
available
as easily as affordably
as possible for muslims all around the
world
and for non-muslims who want to know
about
islam dr bilal please tell me more
tell us more about your university how
long has it been established how long
has it been functioning and how many
students do you have
this university has been
functioning for about
eight years now and
in that span of eight years we have
reached over
250 000 students who registered with us
and taking different courses including
those who are taking actual degree
courses
but the vast majority are taking our
free courses being offered
mashallah that's amazing so many
students alhamdulillah
what's the essence of the university the
essence of it all
is about spreading authentic islamic
knowledge
in fact the motto of the university
itself
is changing the nation that is the
muslim
ummah changing the nation through
education and the whole purpose of this
was to get people away from
other methods which people have taken on
in recent times in the name of islam
using the banners of islam
which are not about education
they're about mayhem
about slaughter
taking lives exploding bodies
blowing up institutions restaurants
shopping centers all kinds of
craziness which is being done in the
name
of islam it's really hijacked
islam the vast majority of muslims have
nothing to do with this at all
authentic knowledge is so important
during these turbulent times you have
many people
sadly to say many uneducated muslims
also who
really are confused about islam and the
media doesn't help out
you have them portraying islam as being
violent because
all they do is pick up on stories of
ignorant uneducated muslims
who might do some evil act
that is actually opposite to islam the
media
has seen to
exploit this circumstance
it sells newspapers it
catches people's attention it makes
people popular
to attack some group and blame
everything on that group before it was
the communists
back in the 50s 1950s etc
you know russia cold war
then after the berlin wall fell and
russia crumbled who else now to blame
muslims the most visible become
the scapegoat the word extremist
is used nowadays a lot can you tell us
who is really an extremist
the extremists are those people who
are using methods espousing principles
which are not from the authentic way of
islam islam was
never gained power in the time of the
prophet
it didn't gain power through violence
the prophet may god's peace and blessing
be upon him could have gathered
the leading companions of his his
disciples the leading
who were ones who were most
you know warrior-like they were
strongest
and then a coup d'etat right there in
mecca
killing the leaders of croatian taking
over mecca and declaring
himself the prophet may god's blessing
must be upon him as the ruler
of mecca and sharia as the law but he
didn't do that
that wasn't his way and to call
to that other way is not to call to
islam that is the communist way
you know you could call it any other way
you want
even the american revolution you know
that was a violent way
but that wasn't the islamic way i agree
with you that's definitely not the way
to share this beautiful way of life with
the world however what is the correct
way
what is the right way to share this
message of peace this message of purpose
that brings solace contentment
satisfaction to the heart
what is the correct way and will you
share some final thoughts with us
islamic way
fundamentally is educating
the prophet may god's peace and blessing
upon him was
an exemplary educator all of the
prophets of god
were educated they were teachers they
taught the message of god
which guided human society
put human lives on the right
path a path which
is beneficial to society a path which is
away from violence except where
necessary
to preserve oneself one's family
one's country so one does not
say well we cannot fight at any
under any circumstance no where it is
necessary to preserve ourselves then
we fight to survive but otherwise
as the quran says 15 there is no
compulsion
in religion so islam is about
educating humankind to the way
of god to the deen i really appreciate
it thank you very much for joining us dr
billah
i'd like to thank you all for listening
to these
brief words of mine on the dean show
and i hope to be able to share some more
with you in the future at the peace and
mercy of
god almighty allah be upon you
and don't forget if you have it
subscribe right now